so I decided Leviathan studio where I've
set up a stick the stick is to give me
feedback on my poi patterns because I
noticed that my patterns have gotten
super sloppy so I've taken on 30 day
challenge and I am going to improve
especially my box empty spin and the
stick gives me some feedback I can see
whether I've got my up loop in my down
loop right on my vertical axis you can
even try to stall up and down the stick
nice feedback and on my box auntie spin
I can really try to paint them and up
the side of the stick to see whether
I've got the pattern the way I want and
I'm definitely seeing improvement
there's two patterns I'm playing with
that switch between anti spin and in
spin one of them who goes between
diamond if you spin and horizontal in
spins it's got a 4/4 rhythm it goes 1 2
3 4 1 2 3 4 1 2 3 4 1 2 I really like
practicing for 4 rhythms or 3 4 but
something I can do musically yes it
makes it a lot more interesting the Box
anti-spin version I'm playing with see
I invite you to do this with me and of
course make up your own patterns and
these are just something that I've
stumbled on so far and once they're
working I'll make new ones and I'll keep
posting what I'm doing if you find that
useful we're going to move on to moving
between where we start combining in spin
and Auntie spin the patterns like this
where we can do a hybrid both auntie
spin both in spin back the hybrids blend
them all together but that's future
videos nick woolsey playboy reporting
from Leviathan studio and it's awesome
here and consider coming for one of the
Leviathan portraits or come to Costa
Rica which is also awesome
I'm hoping it's straight I want to
disappear into the stick but it might
not work
[Music]